[Applause]
thanks so much for being here you just
cracked me up with that move you walk
out of that's one of my favorite moves
in show you walk out and you look
surprised to see me well i got to tell
you you're behind the curtain back there
there's a lot of people telling you
you're ready you're good you're fine you
okay are you ready to go and you can
only say yes so many times before you
start to lose confidence
so when you do come out you've forgotten
why you're here
you're here to talk to me and i'm glad
you're here i see you all the time uh we
will admit this to america we have kids
that are in pre-k together at the same
school and so i'm constantly seeing you
uh dropping off your child sounds so
disappointed
what that sounds so disappointing i
wasn't disappointed i was angry uh no we
always we end up chatting and it's nice
because the schools here are uh they're
very interested in getting the parents
involved right you know they're always
i i've gone in they ask you to do things
can you get involved can you can you
teach somebody have you done that you've
done that i've done i've done a few of
the well our kids are they're four right
i mean so they're pretty uh pretty young
but they do ask some activity
support from the dads did you have you
gone in and done an activity i've done
some stuff i haven't done an activity
yet no
beat dad yeah okay so
um
i sent my agent to do it
well that's good that's okay then you're
fine no i i went in and i taught uh i i
i went in and they said do something and
i went in for whatever reason i was out
of ideas and taught the kids how to do
some fly fishing
how would you do that there's no yeah
well did you take them to a river
there's
there's no better idea than getting a
bunch of four-year-olds around invisible
hooks
that are that are multi-colored and
stuff i couldn't think of a better idea
than that so yes i i brought them in
there no i did it at the classroom i
just brought a rod and reel in there and
and i should i brought it i found it i
got my ipad and i loaded it up from
youtube a fantastic uh
fish being caught i showed them that
then i hooked up the rod and reel i took
them out on that green grassy area in my
uh vest and waders because nothing looks
cooler than that
and uh and i tried you know to show them
how to do it and learn that it's not a
good idea to hand a
kid a 10 foot rod amongst other kids
also i just love the image of anyone
seeing greg kinnear with a rod and reel
no no water anywhere just grass yeah
i just have a tabloid shot where it's
clear that you've lost your mind that's
right he finally went around the bench
it wasn't the coolest look that i've had
i'll say but uh but yeah i was it was uh
it was fun so try to do some stuff over
there ah screw it uh are you are you a
uh would you call yourself a silly dad
my my kids are always saying i'm a silly
dad i like to do and i'm getting the
sense that you might be the same why now
why do they say you're a silly dad i
jump around a lot i mean what do you
mean why anything i do here look how i
make my living all the stuff i do here
works on two and three and
four-year-olds right right
it actually works better on them
i uh yeah you know i do yes i i guess i
do a little bit of uh silliness sure
yeah i'm definitely a silly dad too i
mean it just works i mean the sillier
you are the better it works right and
and i i try to uh come up with different
little things i can uh teach them my
seven-year-old right now i'm trying to
teach her how to speak gibberish so that
she can talk in front of her teachers or
other friends that don't know how to
speak gibberish and and those those
those teachers of those kids won't know
what she's saying oh so it's like a
a little code get stuff past the teacher
what does this sound like gibberish is
uh with the gal of the gift for the guy
to the chocolate guy that the guest
against the gate to the guy the goo with
the god of the gavitager people are not
gonna know what i'm talking about but uh
the guy does anybody speak gibberish
anybody
you've got a whole crowd of gibberish
speakers and you've been doing this show
in english all these years
clearly i screwed up
no you take a word you take like the
word dog and i learned it in high school
because a bunch of my friends we kind of
that's kind of what a nerd i was but we
we learned it and and and then of course
after we graduated we learned that all
the people we thought we were protecting
this language from actually spoken to
but if you take like the word dog it's
uh you break it in two at the vowel and
the consonants so it's da the gog
or the god or or bird would be by the
gerd or or andy would be uh again to the
ghee
had a lot of time on your hands
yeah so they go with you but they got
you the goop of the good to the it to
the goo get the gather the girl for the
gear of the geek with the kick legend
again to the keeper of the goal with the
illness go with the god you're the
course of the gay of the game don't you
think that's good
what did you just say
i i said you put it together very
quickly and people know what you're
saying oh that's incred i i i
that was good yeah that's actually a
useful skill well i just try and pass it
on i mean if you want to use it